[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story taken at gunpoint how 15
Ukrainian orphans escaped from Russia
and the thousands of others left behind
oh
blast off for the world's most powerful
rocket but Elon musk's Starship explodes
just four minutes later
prosecutors drop criminal charges
against actor Alec Baldwin over his
cinematographer's death as filming
resumes in Montana
Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Raab
awaits his fate after Rishi sunak
postponed his verdict on a bullying
inquiry
the first wartime visit to Ukraine by
the head of Nathan as Kiev pushes again
to join the military Alliance
and a fitting send-off family fans and
their dogs Bid Farewell to comedian Paul
O'Grady
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening 15 Ukrainian orphans have
told Sky News how they were taken at
gunpoint by Russian soldiers removed
from their Homeland and illegally
transferred to Russia before making a
remarkable escape to freedom and safety
well the children's ordeal shines a
light on the thousands of others like
them who are still in Russia after being
taken from Ukraine even though it's a
war crime to transport them to a foreign
country
the figures here represent institutions
in regions across Russia and
russian-occupied Crimea where children
have allegedly been sent
some have reportedly been taken
thousands of miles further all the way
to Russia's Far East
Sky News has confirmed these
establishments orphanages summer camps
or boarding schools where pupils get an
education steeped in Russian patriotism
have been taken in Ukrainian children
Moscow claims it's giving them Sanctuary
from the horrors of War but a leading
war crimes investigator told us it
amounts to cultural and physical
genocide our International Affairs
editor Dominic weighorn reports now on
Ukraine's missing children
thousands of children have been taken
from Ukraine by the Russians in this war
this is the story of 15 who escaped
their clutches
[Music]
their ordeal lasted five months and took
them a thousand miles but they have
finally reached Freedom thanks to one
remarkable woman
Natalia was the director of their
orphanage in southern Ukraine when
Russian forces arrived
we know from CCTV footage taken in
another orphanage how the Russian
military has searched for children in
this war Natalia begged the Russians to
let her children go
sh
the day the soldiers came was filmed by
Russian State tv the footage doesn't
show what the children say happened that
they pleaded not to be taken and the
Russians fired their guns to make the
move
fourteen-year-old Dasha describes those
frightening moments
um
they say they were moved against their
will at gunpoints a clear violation of
the laws of war taken from their
orphanage to another in the village of
stephanievka 150 miles Behind Enemy
Lines
then the Russians move them again as
they retreated across the danipra river
fifteen-year-old stas says he feared for
the worst
so maybe
he was right to be worried they were
heading for Russia taken through one
city after another in russian-occupied
Crimea then across the church Straits
and over the Border Natalia's worst
fears had come true
foreign
this is the Fate that could have awaited
them Sky News has found evidence of
Ukrainian children being deported deep
into Russia some are given to Russian
families in these pictures in a city two
and a half thousand miles from home
oh this is sent to camps where we know
children are indoctrinated in putanist
ideology and trained in the use of
weapons
and they're being exploited for
propaganda purposes too in events
presided over by Vladimir Putin himself
the children being made to hug this
Russian soldier are from mariupole a
city destroyed by Putin's military
the Russians say they're rescuing
children from war
but both Putin and his children's rights
commissioner have now been indicted by
the international criminal court for the
war crime of deporting children charges
they've both rejected foreign
but this British war crimes investigator
whose senior evidence says moscow's
claims do not stand scrutiny this is a
clear conditioning of children for
nefarious purposes I think it goes to
the overall criminal plan which is to
extinguish extinguish Ukrainian identity
so we're talking about cultural genocide
and we're also talking about physical
genocide
our 15 orphans Journey ended an escape
from Russia slipping across the border
and finding sanctuary in Georgia
they recall the moments they made it to
Freedom is
they're now waiting until it's safe
enough to go back home against the odds
Natalia has kept her word and led them
to safety is
foreign
hmm it's a hard watch isn't it well
Dominic's uh with me now and Dominic and
this is the culmination of months and
months of work do we know how many
children have been affected and what's
been the response from from Russia well
we're definitely talking about thousands
Yale University have come up probably
the most comprehensive independent
estimate they reckon 6 000 children have
been taken into Russia the ukrainians
say 20 000 and the Russians are quite
open about it they admit they are
transporting unaccompanied Ukrainian
children into Russia but they say
they're doing it for humanitarian
reasons and we heard from Russia's
Deputy ambassador to the UN saying that
it is laughable to say they are taking
children he says they're saving them but
the international criminal court that's
indicted both Putin and his children's
rights commissioner says if that's the
case then the Russians should be using
the Red Cross and the United Nations to
send children home send them back to
Ukraine instead our research shows that
um and others that these children are
going in the other direction they're
going deep into Russia they're being
transported thousands of miles some of
them as far afield as Siberia the young
ones are being distributed amongst
families many of them the older ones as
we're seeing there are going to camps to
schools institutions where they're being
subjected to the same authoritarian
militaristic putanist ideology as young
Russians and they're being told that
Ukraine is now forever Russia so the war
crimes investigator who we presented our
evidence to says that the this seems to
be a systematic attempt to erase their
Ukrainian identity to rustify them and
as we were hearing from him there that
could amount to cultural or physical
genocide
Dominic thank you very much
or you can watch Dominick's full report
on that remarkable escape and what life
is like inside Russian schools camps and
orphanages for those who aren't so lucky
that's Ukraine's missing children here
on Sky News throughout the day tomorrow
scan the QR code to watch on the app
it's the biggest and most powerful
rocket ever made destined eventually to
take Nassau astronauts back into space
after an aborted attempt earlier this
week the SpaceX Starship lifted off from
Texas to huge cheers but it exploded
four minutes later and fell back to
Earth with founder Elon Musk saying only
that his team had learned a lot here's
our Science and Technology editor Tom
Clark
this was the loudest largest and most
powerful rocket ever launched
SpaceX Starship hefted skywards by the
super heavy booster with thrust
equivalent to more than 100 jetliners at
takeoff
Engineers have said just getting off the
launch pad would make this uncrewed test
a success the Houston tracking station
now acquiring the vehicle they got a lot
further than that onboard view from
Starship but Starship failed to separate
from its booster the rocket tumbling
through the atmosphere before breaking
apart
and the gung-ho fail fast world of Elon
Musk SpaceX
this moment was met by cheers
while the excitement will simply put
Starship is the largest rocket anyone
has ever built
the space shuttle was around 60 meters
tall with a 29 ton capacity NASA's
latest Moon rocket SLS block one is a
whopping 98 meters tall Saturn V the
last rocket to go to the moon was bigger
and more powerful still but Starship
bolted on to the heavy booster dwarfs
even that at 120 meters with a 150 tonne
payload capacity but size isn't
everything
thank you
SpaceX dominates the commercial launch
market by making its Rockets reusable
Starship is designed to be the same
Elon Musk didn't look delighted Starship
was supposed to complete an orbit of
Earth before crashing into the sea but
even his critics were impressed by
today's result for a first test launch
of a completely new uh revolutionary
design like this I I'm I'm very happy
with it and I'm sure SpaceX will be too
the point is where when will it get into
space when will it get into orbit and
the Really revolutionary thing about
Starship is the idea of recovering for
reuse and so they're a long way off
SpaceX has proved it learns from its
failures but there'll likely be more
before Starship is ready for astronauts
Bound for the moon and Beyond Tom Clark
Sky News
when Alec Baldwin resumed filming today
on his Hollywood movie he did so
thinking he could soon face trial after
shooting his cinematographer Helena
Hutchins on set tonight prosecutors
confirmed all criminal charges would be
dropped the Stars lawyers told Sky News
they're pleased with the decision
well our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner is outside the set on
Yellowstone film Ranch in Montana
Baldwin was holding the gun with fired
killing Rising Star cinematographer
Helena Hutchins and injuring the film's
director Joel Souza we know that much
because of the huge amount of video
footage that has been put into the
public domain in connection with the
criminal investigation into what
happened but Alec Baldwin has always
denied pulling the trigger always denied
holding any responsibility for Helena
Hutchins death and today New Mexico
prosecutors announcing that they have
dropped involuntary manslaughter charges
which carried a possible 18 months in
prison against Alec Baldwin although
they do reserve the right to charge him
with a lesser offense in the future they
seem to have determined that this gun
could have misfired without the
intervention of the person holding it
the timing of this decision was stunning
though on the very day that filming of
Rost here in Montana is resuming
in the place known as Montana's Paradise
Valley a project resurrected production
on the film rust is restarting 18 months
after Helena Hutchins was shot dead on a
set hundreds of miles from here as the
film's star Alec Baldwin did final
rehearsals he was told involuntary
manslaughter charges against him in
connection with hutchin's death had been
dropped Alec Baldwin and other members
of the cast and crew of rust were doing
last minute preparations here when news
came through that those charges which
were filed in New Mexico had been
dropped a preliminary trial was due to
starting just two weeks time so this was
an incredibly dramatic intervention
and for those preparing to resume
filming a note of relief so Alec is a
consummate professional and I think we
had every confidence in his ability to
act within the movie regardless of
what's going on in any aspect of his
personal life I would say probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served
the top of the Spire of a church is all
that's visible of Yellowstone film Ranch
from the public Road
a poignant reminder that it was while
rehearsing a scene in a church that
Helena Hutchins was shot dead the bullet
lodged in the shoulder of the film's
director Joel Souza a year and a half
later he returned to the set alongside
other members of the original cast and
crew
as part of a wrongful death settlement
Helena Hutchins widower Matthew Hutchins
has become an executive producer on Rust
filming in this remote part of Montana
is expected to last just over three
weeks but opinion is divided on the
decision to complete production Molina a
lot of people as you know look at the
completion of this film and view it as
disrespectful insulting even to Helena's
memory I know that you feel differently
to that so we've had a lot of
conversations about this and because her
husband and family are on board with the
production and her husband Matthew
Hutchins is an executive producer on
this film we are convinced that we are
doing what she wanted what her family
wants and we're not really concerned
about the broader public and for
Helena's art not to be seen I think
would be a much bigger disrespect there
are still at least five outstanding
civil lawsuits against Baldwin and the
other producers of rust but the
Hollywood veteran will now finish this
film an actor and not a criminal
defendant
we're yet to hear in person from Alec
Baldwin but we're yet to hear in person
from Alec Baldwin and but just in the
past couple of minutes he has posted on
Instagram a picture have you of himself
hugging his wife Hilaria uh he wrote I
owe you I owe everything I have to this
woman and to You Luke he writes in
brackets I believe that is a reference
to his lawyer Luke Nicos so Alec Baldwin
clearly very pleased that these charges
have been dropped and just another note
on the production of this film rust I'm
told uh by a source that as much of what
Helena Hutchins filmed on the original
set of the film rust will be maintained
in the final version of this film uh
when it is released and the cast and
crew of this film those who have signed
up to see it through to completion
believe that they are doing it in honor
of the memory of their and Helena
Hutchins
Martha thank you
he put integrity at the heart of his
Premiership and tonight prime minister
Rishi sunak is yet to decide the fate of
his Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Robb
several hours after receiving a report
into bullying allegations Mr Rob who's
been under investigation for five months
over eight formula complaints has
repeatedly insisted that he acted
professionally Skye's political editor
Beth Rigby reports
that the question that's long followed
Dominic Raab around and now after five
months of this I'm confident I've had
profession at all times I'm confident I
pay professionally throughout a behaved
profession at all times a decision on
his fate now imminent after the report
investigating bullying allegations
against the deputy PM was handed to his
boss Rishi sunak who now has to decide
whether his Deputy stays or goes that's
all things no turning into a fast can
you imagine being a civil servant who's
raised the complaint the Prime Minister
used to think about what it would be
like if it was him in that situation
he's the first minister of the Civil
Service he has a responsibility to his
civil servants to ensure that they're
protected from building harassment and
that they are treated with respect this
is not treating those civil servants
with respect the allegations of bullying
concern Mr Rob's time as a cabinet
minister across three different
department
taking in eight separate complaints with
a number of complainants and while his
accusers await a decision others seek to
defend him I must have attended hundreds
of meetings with him with civil servants
and MPS and other officials and and not
once did I ever witness him behaving in
a manner that could be described as
bullying conflicting interpretations of
his behavior but the times of reference
of this investigation clear to establish
the facts and to be completed as swiftly
as possible with the Prime Minister as
the ultimate judge and tonight he's
still weighing up the verdict I'm told
the prime minister is taking his time to
go through the report and consider it
thoroughly because this is a really
difficult decision for Rishi sunak
Dominic Raab is one of his most loyal
lieutenants and a trusted political
allies so to part company with him will
come at a personal cost but this is
about politics too if Rob goes then the
Prime Minister will face questions as to
why he appointed him in the first place
and what he knew when if Rob stays the
Prime Minister risks a backlash from the
Civil Service and questions about
whether or not his really is a
government of Integrity
Dominic Robb has seen the report and
maintains he behaved professionally but
the opposition calling for the PM to
adjudicate and fast the Prime Minister
really should be able to read the report
make up his mind and get on with it stop
dithering and delaying and we do need
people to have faith and politics next
month the country's faith will be tested
at the local elections not an explicit
Judgment of the PM but of his party and
his record this the third cabinet
minister of Rishi sunak's short
Premiership to face the sack the weight
continues Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster
well earlier in the program you heard
the story of 15 Ukrainian orphans who
were illegally transferred to Russia
Today NATO's secretary-general visited
Ukraine for the first time since the War
Began where he delivered the clearest
signal of support yet ahead of Ukraine's
next big offensive here's our security
and defense editor Deborah Haynes
a show of respect for Ukraine's war dead
and a show of defiance to the Kremlin
the NATO Chief had previously kept his
distance since Russia launched its
full-scale War Ukraine is not a member
of the alliance yet and there was
concern his presence here might be
viewed as provocative no such caution
now yen stoltenberg in Kiev greeted by
the president
his country is preparing to launch a big
counter-offensive and needs all the
support it can get
we do not know when this war will end
but we know that Russian aggression is a
toxic pattern that must be stopped let
me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the Euro
Atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible welcome words for
this wartime leader but he'll want
actions too
we interpret this first visit of the
Secretary General during the full-scale
war as a sign that the alliance is ready
to start a new chapter of ambitious
decisions in relations with Ukraine
it's a goal that will enrage Russia's
Vladimir Putin who's also becoming more
daring earlier this week apparently
visiting a part of Southern Ukraine
occupied by his troops back in Russia
the president praised those who've gone
to fight
they set an example of Devotion to the
motherland and its interests and now
they're standing for our historical
territories protecting people the
inhabitants of those territories
the NATO Chief was shown the reality of
this so-called protection the town of
butcher outside Kiev where dozens were
killed
now a place of reflection even as
Ukraine prepares for the next bloody
stage of this war Deborah Haynes Sky
News
at least 78 people have been killed and
73 others injured in a crush in the
yemeni capital tsunam a warning you may
find the images coming out distressing
hundreds had gathered in the hope of
receiving a charitable cash donation in
the final days of Ramadan Witnesses
claimed Panic were sparked after armed
houthis fired into the air and hit an
electrical wire causing it to explode
hundreds of well-wishers lined the
streets of oldington in Kent today to
pay their final respects to the comedian
Paul O'Grady dogs from Battersea dogs
and cats home formed a guard of honor
and in a nod to his alter ego Lily
Savage the star's coffin was topped with
an arrangement of lilies as either
Bennett reports
[Applause]
in death as in life Paul O'Grady still
draws a crowd hundreds lining the root
of his funeral Cortez through this quiet
corner of Kent to say goodbye to not
just a neighbor but a National Treasure
it's important to be here today because
he's just amazed special
O'Grady's husband accompanied The
Carriage with one of the couple's dogs
as they laid to rest not just the
Entertainer but his drag queen alter ego
too Lily Savage's distinctive hairpiece
a typically witty centerpiece and what
else but lilies to top the coffin I
really miss him because he was a great
great talent he knew when to hang up the
dress he knew exactly what he was doing
and his love for Animals I mean I
remember lots of times talking to me and
saying I prefer animals to human beings
among the mourners Rolling Stones
guitarist Ronnie Wood and the comedians
Joe brand and Julian Clary
[Music]
the cast of comics it was the guard of
Honor outside the church that put a
smile on people's faces dogs from
Battersea dogs and cats home in
recognition of the worker Grady did to
help it since his death a tribute fund
set up by the charity has raised nearly
three hundred thousand pounds he was a
big big part of Battersea and it feels
like a little bit of battersei's Hearts
has slowed down today as well because of
Paul
he was a Saturday night TV staple but
his Fame didn't Define him remembered
here as a man of the people and their
pets either Bennett Sky News
that has the makings of a tale fit for a
Hollywood movie A struggling Football
Club new millionaire owners and possibly
this weekend the ever elusive promotion
wrexham's Hometown fans and those
traveling from further afield are hoping
for their own fairy tale ending as
Katarina vatatsu reports
please
Welsh pop band The Declan swans used to
sing about the highs but mainly the lows
of being wrexham football fans
[Music]
the non-league club was heading for
relegation but two years ago came new
Hollywood owners a documentary and
crucially investment that's LED almost
fairy tale-like to a chance this
Saturday for a promotion back into
League football we've had the jackpot
with these owners it's just transformed
the whole town the community it's a
happy place to live everybody's talking
about football
um you know over the years when you've
seen youngsters with like Liverpool man
united Man City Chelsea tops all the
kids wear wrexham now Ryan Reynolds and
Rob mcelhenney the new owners of rexham
AFC
welcome to wrexham followed actors Ryan
Reynolds and Rob mcelhenney taking on
football and life in this small Welsh
City making stars of its locals like the
Declan swans well I can tell you it's
all here it's all real attracting new
fans from across the world had you even
heard of wrexham before not once never
never never
what didn't even know how to spell it at
first Michael Starkey lives in South
Alabama and loved the film he's never
left the states but his first flight
ever will be here for Saturday's game I
never would have thought even you know
three four five years ago that I would
be uh shoving myself on an airplane to
go to the other side of the planet so
watch a fifth tier Welsh football club
and as we were still in the company of
wrexham royalty yeah
the club's had so many tough times and
you know we've had supports who've
followed this club Home and Away through
all those tough periods and uh you know
it would be very special if we could
finish the job off for now the owner's
box and the stands are empty on Saturday
guaranteed they'll be singing
Catherine evatazzi Sky News wrexham
fingers crossed for them well that was
Sky News at 10 coming up we'll take a
first look at tomorrow's newspapers in
the Press preview including this story
on the front of the Metro after the
SpaceX rocket explosion their headline
Elon we have a problem tonight we're
going to be joined by The Economist
Carol Malone and the editor of The
Courier in Dundee David Clegg to stay
with us
thanks
[Music]